good morning Hank it's Tuesday thank you
for the brilliant and astonishingly
comprehensive youtube.com slash how to
vote in every state after seeing it I
went on Twitter and asked eligible
American voters who don't intend to vote
what their reasoning was and today I
want to respond to the six concerns I
heard the most number one by far I do
not want to choose between the lesser of
two evils two things first in most
states there will be more than two
candidates on the presidential ballot
secondly I think maybe you do want to
choose between a lesser of two evils you
know because it's the less evil choice
by not voting you're essentially ranking
the candidates as equally evil which i
think is technically impossible given
their vastly different policy positions
also you're not just voting for
president I know it might feel that way
because of national media coverage but
the elections down the ballot are
extremely important it's not just your
Senators and US Congress people it's
your state legislators who make the laws
in your state the school board members
who decide what the curriculum is going
to look like in your schools those
elections have a massive effect on the
community you live in ok concern number
two I am not informed on the issues and
or don't care so if you don't care who
your elected representatives are we
agree on this one
you should not vote but it's not really
that hard to get well-informed you can
go to youtube.com slash how to vote in
every state find your state find a
sample ballot then you can go to the
candidates websites or if it's a race
for US Senate or Congress there's a
great website called ballot of pedia
link in the doobly-doo and if you want
us to make videos about candidates
policy plans and proposals let us know
in comments what topics you'd like for
us to explore concern three I'm a
Republican in a blue state or a Democrat
in a red state so my vote doesn't matter
first your down ballot votes might
matter but I'd argue your vote matters
regardless like you're right that your
vote isn't going to tip the election but
by not voting you're making politicians
in your state believe that their state
is less politically diverse than it
actually is and I think that's dangerous
because a strong minority has a
moderating effect on the party in power
both at national and local levels and
God knows we could use some moderation
concern for the system is corrupted by
money and votes don't actually matter I
agree that the system is corrupted by
money I just don't think we're gonna fix
it by not voting because not voting out
of protest looks to the system exactly
the same as not voting out of apathy
also I don't think money negates the
power of your vote and I think rich
people know this actually like
fifty-seven point five percent of
eligible American voters voted in the
2012 election
99% of millionaires did literally
number-5 illness or disability or
transportation problems one of my many
frustrations with u.s. voting laws is
that in lots of states it's really
difficult to vote if you are sick or
disabled but find your stayed in the
links below and check out your options
there usually are some also if you need
a ride on Election Day most local
political parties will pick you up and
take you to the polls even if you're not
voting for their candidates okay lastly
number six I am overwhelmed with the
process of registering and have never
voted before and find this whole thing
intensely scary yeah I can relate like
16 years ago in August of 2000 I just
moved to Chicago but I didn't know where
I technically lived like I was sleeping
in the walk-in closet of a Chicago
apartment that my name wasn't on the
lease of but my driver's license said I
lived with mom and dad back in Florida
where most of my stuff was and it was a
stressful and overwhelming time and I
had no idea how to register and suddenly
I looked up and the deadline and passed
it's true that the system makes it hard
for people who move around a lot to vote
but I lacked the fortitude to stand up
to that system and it's one of the great
shames of my life I feel like I failed
my community and myself and also people
who live far away from me who
desperately want the opportunity that I
took for granted
of course my vote wouldn't have changed
the outcomes in any elections but the
combined votes of even 10% of the
thousands of people who were like me
that would have changed some outcomes if
you're eligible to vote in the United
States I'm asking you to become a
registered and informed voter and to
make your voice heard even if it's hard
in fact especially if it's hard Hank
I'll see you on Friday